welcome everybody to
part three of this uh video
series where i walk through
a run of the chess.com uh
puzzle rush survival mode where
essentially i have unlimited time to
solve as many
chess problems as possible of increasing
difficulty
now in the first two
videos in this series which i will link
below
i did the first 40 problems of the
puzzle rush
run and in this video we will be doing
problems 40 to 50 or 40 to 55 depending
on
how much time it's going to take us uh
to solve each one
and to remind you the rationale behind
this uh
series is to walk through every single
problem to explain
how i solve them whether the problems
are easy or hard and
you know in this part the one thing i
wanted to say before we launch in is
that it's very very important
if you are in this to truly improve if
you have a board lying around
i will be doing a lot of analysis
uh because these problems are quite
difficult there's bound to be
variations and and longer variations
than previous
previously in in the problem so you're
very much welcome to set these positions
up on your board
and follow along that will really help
with the visualization
with that being said i will try to make
all of the variations
very clear and without further ado let
us jump into problem number 41
and here is black to move so now we have
a situation where
multiple white pieces are hanging and
these types of situations
tend to intimidate people because it
seems very chaotic
but we have to approach this very
methodically and simply understand
the difference between capturing the
multiple pieces available for capture
so if we take the knight with either the
pawn or the queen actually the bishop
can move so if we take with the queen
that looks like a fork but the bishop
could actually
walk back to e2 and cover the check
now if we take the bishop however what
happens is that the knight on e5 is
and remains pinned so we want to take
the bishop because that's a higher
degree of
urgency because this knight is actually
not going anywhere
so it's imperative to take the bishop
okay he takes on f7 or the queen which
you know it gets a pawn for the piece
but white still loses a piece we take
the queen
and we take the knight so a lot of chaos
seem to be on the board but in these
situations we simply compare
um the situation that arises after we
capture each of the pieces nothing to it
okay so here we have white to move and
white is in check so that really limits
our options it would be great if we
could take the roof but we can't because
we're in check
and you know first i start with some
observations as we usually do
um and what i want to make very clear is
that even
when we solve the more complicated
problems if i've done this right
you know the process of solving them
doesn't really change you know the
difficulty certainly rises and
there might be more variations involved
but the actual underlying process of
solving these problems doesn't actually
change and hopefully i'll be able to
inspire people to realize that
you too with enough time and persistence
can solve these problems
and not get intimidated by you know the
rating attached to them so
we're in check and it's clear that we're
also attacking blacks black's king we've
got a lot of pieces clustered
around black's king this bishop is also
hanging you know there is a direct mate
threat rook h7 so
it appears to me that one of our first
tasks has to be
to stave off the checks you know to
escape the checks as quickly as possible
and with that in mind let's try to
compare the possible
king escapes so we have king h1 king g2
and king f1 let's start with those and
if none of those work we'll look at
different ways of blocking the check
so king f1 seems the least
likely to me because it steps right into
that rook's x-ray on the f-file
we'll return to this move a little bit
later but let's first start with the
moves that
seem you know likeliest to be correct
and then if they don't work
then we'll look at the more sort of
paradoxical options let's look at king
g2 for a second now the key question is
does king g2
step into the path of any other checks
well
yes it does um king g2 does step into
queen d2
check and well the king cannot go to h3
because that is
blocked by the bishop so the king has to
go back to
either h1 or g1 and well that i suppose
allows another check with the queen on
on c1 this time
and and the line goes on so let's put
that aside that does not seem to be the
most convincing way
of escaping the checks that leaves us
with king h1 let's take a look at that
for a second so king h1
do we see any other plausible checks for
black
well let's take a look can blackjack
here no
here no or d1 no all three of those
squares are indeed covered by white's
knight
so purely from the point of view of
escaping
all the checks immediately uh king h1
seems to be the move and i see no reason
to allow any checks here so i think just
on the basis of that we could already go
king h1 bingo
now he's taken our rook we have to
recapture his
and he goes rookie so with some of these
problems you see that the solutions
are longer and there's more hurdles in
the way
now the key question to ask yourself
after rookie is can we take the bishop
right
it's clear that queen g7 does not is not
shackling because the queen covers the
square
so what is black cooking up after we
take the bishop well probably he's going
to give us this check on e1 which looks
scary but let's actually flesh that out
for a second
rookie one check um i feel like i set
out with a canadian accent
man i'm working with some canadians
recently don't hold it against me
okay so queen 67 rookie one check
well king g2 right and again in these
positions you want to be very methodical
and not get intimidated by
oh you know there's so many checks just
if you kind of plunge in and calculate
sometimes you'll see that the position
is simpler than it looks and i think
that's the case here
so queen takes c7 rookie one king g2 he
can give a check on the g1 square let me
draw it with
different colored arrows to make this a
little bit clearer so rookie one check
um then and then king g2
then um how do i try i need to draw oh
there we go
rochi one check i don't know if that
made it more confusing or clear but in
any case the king just gives to h3
and you might say wait a second is there
a bishop remember we've captured the
bishop on d7
clearing out the h3 square and as a side
note that's one important piece of
advice
when you're calculating a lot of people
forget that certain pieces have been
taken off the board
and they assume that moves are illegal
because there's a piece guarding a
square but that piece has already been
captured so make sure that
when you're calculating and visualizing
you try to sort of take
stock of which pieces have been taken
off the board explicitly because that
can really help you avoid that mistake
and once the king escapes to h3 well
black can take the rook there with check
but
we can essentially i think take a
shortcut and and stop there
uh because it's it's pretty clear to me
that black is going to
run out of checks and white is going to
end up at least a piece up
so there isn't any need to flesh things
out any further there we go
as long as we know that we're not
getting checkmated the problem has been
solved
okay next next problem so what do we
have here well
i immediately my eyes are just drawn as
i'm sure yours are it's a white skin and
the fact that it is literally surrounded
by pieces
now those who are perhaps more familiar
with these types of positions we'll
realize that
white has played this move g3 probably
to fianchetto a bishop on g2 but that
bishop
has been taken off the board uh which
means that white has
all of these light-squared weaknesses
right around his king which is of course
very problematic
because black black's got this bishop on
h3 and it might seem possible to set up
what
i think the cool kids now call a lobster
pincer mate with a queen ending up on g2
now how can we go about doing that well
the first move that comes to my mind
is actually and we can use the sort of
checks captures and threats
um shortcut to get ourselves to look at
these moves but
queen takes f3 is a move that comes to
my mind
um because i see that if if the pawn
takes the queen then i capture the rook
with checkmate
and well how did i see that move will i
notice this bishop on h3
is essentially covering up the king's
only potential escape score on the
second rank
so i realized that well first rank
checkmates could potentially be possible
here
okay so with these problems one of the
sources of difficulty that
you know that we see is is actually
there are some very very tricky
defensive moves
that are featured in some of these
problems
and we have to take note of these
defensive moves and be very disciplined
about trying to find them so
after queen takes f3 one thing that
white has here
if we look at the whole position we look
at all of white's pieces
and we take a look at the screen on b7
white can actually capture the rook on
c8
with check and after bishop takes c8
then he could capture the queen and
notice that the bishop again is no
longer covering the g2 square so
taking the rook with on e1 was that
would not be made the king would be able
to move to g2
so what's going on in that position well
black has two bishops and white has only
one bishop so black is up a piece
so that would already satisfy
essentially the expectations of this
puzzle
now maybe some of you are looking at
this and saying well wait a minute why
don't we switch the order of operations
here and try to get that lobster pincer
mate
and take on e2 with the rook first
taking the defender away
from the knight and then we take the
knight and deliver the mate on g2 well
that actually i think is inaccurate and
the reason why
is much the same as the defensive
resource after queen takes f3
immediately except it's more effective
so
follow carefully if rook takes c2 what
white does is he takes the rook on c8
with check
attacking black's queen so black has to
take the queen and then white takes the
rook on e2
and guess what white has two rooks for
the queen the knight on f3 is no longer
hanging two rooks for the queen is
approximately balanced
that's not good enough so it's a lot
better to end up a piece up
than to end up in that unbalanced
position so we do indeed
take here take here and take here
okay another situation in which
it's clear that white has you know quite
the overwhelming advantage he's got an
ex
extra exchange he's got this past pawn
he's got a huge attack
on black's king
and it seems that the first order of
business
is to get out of the checks and i think
a quick look reveals that king f2 is a
pretty absurd move it walks right into
queen e3 check so
well i'm not even talking about queen d1
problem 80 that might be the solution
but not yet so king h2 is an only move
now
one very quick note before i make the
move um i think that a lot of people are
under the impression that you
aren't really supposed to make moves
until you've calculated out the whole
sequence
i don't entirely agree with that because
at the end of the day why are we solving
these problems we're solving them to get
better at real chess
and in real chess if there was a move
that you knew
was correct okay there was a move you
knew you had to make
would you hold off on that move because
somewhere down the line you didn't
exactly know how to proceed i mean no
that would be absurd right so i think
that we can allow ourselves
to make forced moves in puzzles to make
our task easier there's nothing
particularly wrong with that i think
that
once again we're trying to mimic real
tournament surroundings okay so f3
that's a move that makes a lot of noise
it looks intimidating but let's actually
unpack what it's doing what is it doing
what
i mean we can take the pawn with two
different pieces
but one thing that's important to
consider whenever a pawn is pushed
squares have been left behind that pawn
that are now accessible to pieces okay
this is true
literally mathematically true of any
pawn move especially these types of far
advanced spawn moves
with the weak king you want to check
which squares have been left behind and
here the f4 square has been left behind
that is the square that the queen could
give a check from
and that would not be a very desirable
check
um in my book to allow potentially but
it might be it's just something to
consider so
from a logical perspective taking the
pawn with the queen
seems to be logical but
in these problems like i said it's
important not to rush and appraise
yourself of
all the possibilities before you make a
move and
if we look a little bit deeper okay
let's imagine that we take the pawn of
the queen
when we take the pawn with a queen we
relinquish
some of the attack on black's king which
gives the pieces around black's king
i.e the bishop a little bit more freedom
which means that after we take the pawn
of the queen
the bishop can actually take d6 okay
why couldn't he take d6 earlier because
the queen had this devastating track on
h8
and if the bishop takes this pawn and
you count the material
we see that black actually has a bishop
and a pawn for a rook
which is a little bit of a material
advantage for the side of the rock but
it's not a lot
and if you look even closer you'll see
that after he takes the pawn of the
bishop black has this very nasty threat
of a discovered attack against white's
king um
which which would win the queen if the
queen remained on f3 so
we'll put that aside i don't think that
that is very clear
let's take a look at what other options
we have in this position and once again
technically speaking when we talk about
checks captures and threats right
the method of actually looking for
checks captions
loses its effectiveness if you try to
like do self-selection if you try to
be if you try to kind of pare down the
decision tree and say well this couch
looks absurd i'm not even going to look
at it
you know what that's going to lessen the
effectiveness of this method because
every method of searching for moves in
chess
essentially has the ultimate aim
of making you kind of think like a chess
computer and if you know anything about
chess computers you'll know that they
literally in any position look at every
possible legal move okay
they look at every possible legal move
and that way they don't miss the stuff
that humans miss now what is it that
humans miss well humans most moves
that to the superficial glands
might seem ridiculous or something that
shouldn't be considered
and so we should be aware of that when
we're examining very chaotic positions
so for that reason
let's take a look at all of the possible
captures here
so that brings us to g takes f3 and i
think that move suffers from much the
same faults that queen takes f3 suffers
from black has a check on f4
and he has also a check on d2 and he can
actually use the queen then to capture
that pawn on d6
i'm just not sure that that yields quite
enough
um of an advantage so again we're gonna
put that aside and we're gonna look at
some of the other options
what are the other captures well this
capture and this capture just give up a
queen
but what about this capture on f8 let's
take a look at it for a second okay
if the king captures on f8 i notice that
the king is
out of the e7 square and queen h8 there
is actually
checkmate okay it's actually checkmate
but wait a moment after rook takes f8
black does not have to take the rook he
can deliver this check on f4
which looks very nasty and then we have
another one of those tasks where you
have to escape the
checks and we can notice that we can
block that check with the move g2 to g3
then the queen has only one check
possible right
d2 this would be a great moment if you
have a board lying around you're welcome
to make those moves on the board
as i'm saying them or you could attempt
to visualize them it's not such a long
line
so to repeat take the bishop queen f4
check g3 queen d2 check
okay and then the king goes up to h3
and actually black does have one more
check you can give the check on g2 with
the queen
but then the king escapes to g4 and
white is completely safe
and you could almost take a shortcut
there when a queen is delivering a check
checks like this to a king that's
surrounded by its own pawns and pieces
chances are there's gonna be a way to
escape the checks
so we could use our intuition to
determine that but as we see
it's not that difficult to calculate out
and so rook takes that fate i believe
offers by far the most convincing path
to victory here we go queen f4 check
notice that other moves here do not
yield the same results king h3
allows another check so it seems to me
that g3
is really the most convincing and there
we go
a difficult problem for sure but not an
insurmountable one we broke it down into
several smaller tasks
and notice the key to finding that move
rook takes f8 we forced ourselves to
look at
all of the captures not just the obvious
ones
so don't do that intuitive
self-selection
when in a very sharp position force
yourself to look at moves
that might seem you know at first glance
a little bit absurd okay
so we have a position with white to move
here
and i will say by the way that that
these actually take me a while to solve
so as i'm talking it through i'm
literally solving it it's not like i've
seen this before and i've already know
the solution i'm you know
i'm also solving it as i'm talking which
is what makes this so interesting to me
and hopefully to you as well
so let's try to figure out what the heck
is going on here now
once again a situation where material is
equal but i don't really care about that
it's clear that this game is going to be
decided by an attack on
one of the kings you know both kings are
very weak black's king
is particularly weak because it is
surrounded here this g6 spawn
can offer um its control over several
squares
you know there's a check on h6 here you
know there's a lot of stuff that white
can
can do in a position like this um so
let's try to figure out you know
what what are the specific things that
white can actually do
in terms of attacking black's king so
first we start with chuck's captures and
threats
um well the only captures is b takes a5
which could
literally not be more irrelevant than
this and watch that be the solution
so we can we can discount vtx a5 now
let's transition to the checks well
there's
rook h8 chuck that seems to blunder the
rook and i don't
see a potential benefit to that you can
give a check with a pawn which
is very doubtful because the pawn is
what seems to be one of the main drivers
of the attack so you can take the pawn
let's say the queen
um and we don't have a follow-up and we
can give a check on h6 with the queen
which might look a little bit more
tempting but once again
the bishop just blocks that check and uh
i don't think that white has
a good follow-up there but let's
transition to threats
could we threaten any of black's pieces
and in
this regard one thing that i recommend
is to start with the pieces that are
undefended the pieces that are not
protected by any other pieces or pawns
in this case
all of black's pieces are undefended so
it's a little bit less effective but
here we could perhaps spot the piece
that seems to be
the most attackable and to me that looks
like the bishop on f6 because
well it's the closest to black's king
now how can we
pose a threat to this bishop well we
can't use our bishop we can't use our
rook can we use our queen
we can't put it here we could put it on
f2 wait a second we could put it on f2
and that not only attacks the bishop but
it pins the bishop to the king and then
when we when we set a pin that means
the squares that the bishop was formerly
covering are now accessible to our
pieces
are there any such squares we might be
interested in accessing there is
look at this h8 square that was
previously inaccessible to
to white's rook that's a pretty darn
juicy square i would say
so we got to keep that in mind so queen
f2 how can black defend the bishop let's
not get overwhelmed here be methodical
he can defend it in a variety of ways
with his queen right he can play queen
g5
26 queen takes d4 it's all and
and when you are considering your
opponent's defensive replies you want to
sort of group them into categories
because
sometimes that makes it easier and less
overwhelming
and sometimes an entire category of
different moves could have the same
response to it and i think that's the
case here
now remember i mentioned that this rook
had this check on h8 well let's take a
look at that let's say queen f2 let's
take a representative response
to ground this in reality let's say
black i don't know plays
queen to g5 and we give
a check on h8 with the rook okay
the king has to move to one of two
squares either e7 or g7
and then if you look very carefully at
that position i also mentioned
noticing the undefended pieces well this
rook is also undefended
so what we can do is drop the rook back
to h7 chuck skewering the king to the
rook and then when the king moves away
we will pick off an entire black rook
what's important here is not getting
fixated and tunnel visioning the king
but also looking at all of black's
pieces and how
they figure and how they how they you
know
be a part of this this attack in general
when you're attacking it's not only
about going for checkmate it's also
about
using the weak king position perhaps to
win material
okay so that category seems to have been
dealt with what are the other ways of
defending that bishop well
the king can defend that bishop i can
step forward to g7 or e7 but none of
those moves
once we refuted the queen defenses those
moves are not intimidating because
he steps right into the skewer and so we
win the rook
immediately well are there any other
ways of defending the bishop i don't see
any right
he can defend it with his king he can
defend it with this queen he cannot
defend it with his rook because
well that g6 one is really the unsung
hero
it's the driving force behind all of
this
um the pawn just takes the rook so i
think we can safely play queen f2
and indeed the response chosen by the
algorithm is queen g5 check and we can
safely
now normally i would spend a little bit
more time actually verifying
my conclusions there rather than playing
the moves immediately but for full
effect
you know we can see that our logic there
was actually
um was actually very very good okay so
what i might do because you know these
problems are taking
us a while so i might do one or two more
because i want to keep this video to
sort of a reasonable length i want to
give people a chance to internalize some
of the advice that i've shared
um so let's go ahead and do two more
problems uh
something like that and then pause and
you know at some point
i myself will start getting problems
wrong because they become
incredibly difficult um so i'll decide
what to do then i might do another
video on like one problem uh but anyway
i'll cross that bridge when i get there
in the meantime let's settle on two more
exercises
uh for for now and uh it seems that our
hands are indeed full and our work cut
out for us in this exercise what the
heck is going on here
well first of all materially we have
four pieces four minor pieces right yeah
two bishops and two nights
black has two rooks a knight and a
bishop and he's also got a pawn that's
threatening to promote so
it is very clear to me that we need to
deliver checkmate here that is a
conclusion we can safely make here
because black is overwhelmingly up
material i mean it's not even freaking
close
and the other thing is this king is
almost out of squares right it is no g2
square no g1 square that's covered by
the knight
it's effectively only got oops no what
am i
doing i don't even know why i'm trying
these out it's actually got only two
squares and we can take
one of them away with a bishop check on
d3 which is i think what we should start
with
because that seems sensible so bishop d3
check and then
king e1 let's take a moment to think
about that position
and one thing that i'll mention as i
think about this is that
a lot of times people assume these
positions every move has to be with
check that's not necessarily entirely
true
there could be quiet moves that are made
to deprive
the king of potential escape squares and
that move doesn't have to be a check so
and a lot of difficulty in chess
actually comes from
so-called quiet but deadly moves moves
that don't come with track they don't
look particularly intimidating or
deadly but they are because you know
they fulfill some sort of crucial
purpose such as taking away a square
from a king so
you have to look for these kinds of
moves and i'll
tackle that separately you know in
separate videos that i'll make but
right now i'll just say that you should
be aware of their existence and you
should not be
too surprised when one of those moves
pops up
uh because that's just a part of uh
combinations and
and checkmates and chess and tactics is
is
knowing when to give a check and play
forcefully and knowing when to make a
quiet move
okay so back to the problem at hand
bishop d3 checking e1
now can we deliver any more checks to
the king well unfortunately we
can't deliver any effective ones right
g3 is covered by the knight
c3 is covered by the pawns by the way
both of those moves would have been
checkmate had it not been for
these pieces which immediately leads me
to
ask whether i can distract or deflect uh
either of these either either this pawn
or this piece but the answer is no it's
clear that
i can't do that um given the time frame
that i'm operating in
um like i can try to like play knight f4
but but that will remove one of the
pieces that's participating in the
checkmate so
i have too few pieces um to assign one
of them the role of just sacrificing
himself for the knight of the pawn it
seems to me that
this has to be more direct than that
okay so this check does not seem to work
at least initially
okay what else can we generate in the
first position well
there's a couple of other checks but
they don't seem effective there's knight
d2 check
um and that allows two potential escapes
right king e2
being the one that seems most sensible
you know moving the king toward the
center so it has more escape squares
then we could give i guess a check on g1
and he would go king e3 we give a
smattering of checks but
you know we're not we're actually
drawing it farther away from checkmate
so that doesn't seem good we can give 93
check and once again he just goes king
e2
and he is threatening to take that
knight um we barely even have a good
check there it is
clear that we're not trackmanning him
then
so that leads me to the question of
quiet moves can we make a
quiet move in this position to deprive
the king
as we discussed of one of the one of its
escape squares
well the king has to escape squares e1
and e2 so let's start to look at moves
that take away either one or preferably
both of these escape squares and that's
what we'll
ask ourselves is there a move that takes
away both there are actually two such
moves
and both of them involve our king right
king d1 and king d2
so let's take one of them as kind of a
representative sample as we did in the
last example to see if this is even
plausible
um and if yes we'll flesh this out
further so
let's say for example king to d1 that
threatens
checkmate on d3 right with the bishop
and uh hopefully everyone's following
along
uh but here's the thing right
um there's a couple of things that black
do there to stop that checkmate he could
either
and i think i talked about it talked
about this in the previous video he
could either
cover the checkmating square or create a
new escape square for his king
um i will make a separate video on
basically defensive methods when faced
with the threat of checkmate
that can help you find these defensive
moves but for now as a shorthand
we can create a square for the game we
can cover that defensive we can cover
that checkmating square
and unfortunately black has both options
available at his disposal he can make a
queen
right black can make a queen and the
point is not to make a queen it is to
open up that g2 square for the king uh
which will be a huge escape square it
seems that once the king reaches g2
white's just not going to have the
firepower available to really
causing any damage once again this h5
knight guards the f4 square and it seems
that the same thing happens after king
to d2
black can promote to a queen and i don't
sing anything there i mean we can give a
check with a bishop
king goes to you know two to g two we
can give another check with a bishop
king captures the knight and on the king
goes so you know we can scrap this
entirely so let's continue to look for
quiet moves here
um that potentially fulfill the role of
somehow we need to deprive the king of
these
squares we simultaneously need to
somehow
take care of the threat of promotion so
let's take a moment
here to think about this um so what do
we have at our disposal here
i might actually have to go into a
couple of moments of silence here and
myself try to generate um
some of these moves and some of these
possibilities so i'm going to do that
right now i'm going to think about this
for a couple of moments
and share my thoughts in a second and i
very much encourage you to do the same
i'm sitting here
you know in my apartment solving this
problem i'm not you know just because
i'm a gm doesn't mean i see stuff
automatically and
that is actually one of the things i
hope to make clear in my youtube channel
in general is like everything is a
process and everything is a logical
process
so set this position up on your board
and uh hopefully you can reach
these key insights faster than i can um
so i'll give myself about
15 20 seconds of thought here and uh
you know then i'll share some of my
thoughts and once again i encourage you
to do the same so
here we go okay
it's probably gonna be the most watched
like silence during a youtube video ever
i got it wow now this is going to be
beautiful folks and i'm going to attempt
to explain how
how i saw this what was the light bulb
moment and if you want to keep thinking
about it by all means doesn't matter
what your rating is
you can do it okay this is the beauty of
chess everyone
can solve difficult problems um it's
just a matter of discipline and
and being willing to make mistakes so
here's the thing what i did was return
to the
to the move bishop d3 check because i
realized that
there's really no way mathematically to
deprive the king
a of these two squares and b to stop
promotion
i realized that like that's too much to
ask of any one move
um which is a shortcut and you know
there still might be such a move but i
figure that's
very unlikely so i returned to the move
bishop d3 check okay because it
it already takes care of that task and
it brings the king onto a square
where it has no um it has no escape
square so it really lessens the flow now
here's the next thing that i did
i asked myself okay let me wipe the
slate clean let me assume that there
were no rules in chess
where could i what could hypothetically
be
the checkmating construction that wins
the game okay
and when i ask this i am ignoring
temporarily rules pins whatever
i'm simply trying to understand whether
there even is a potential checkmate in
construction and
when you ask that question that way well
i did discover one thing i discovered
that
this knight on c4 it could end up on g2
okay
it could end up on g2 and that is
checkmate
so if you imagine this bishop on d3 king
e1 if this knight from c4
comes to g2 the king has no escapes the
bishop on d3 covers f1
knight on h3 covers f2 king on c1 covers
the two
other escape squares we don't actually
need this bishop on e5
and that's another key insight now why
can't we get the knife there why can't
we play the move
knight c4 to e3 and
attack g2 and threaten to go there well
because the knight is pinned right and
why is the knight pinned because we've
moved the bishop out from c2
exposing the pin and so the sort of
sub-task that i had there is what can we
get rid of the pin
well we can take the rook but that
doesn't seem forcing enough and the
other rook could
could replace the captured one could we
get rid of the pen any other ways well
i thought about this for a second and i
thought yes we can we can
actually use this bishop to deliver a
check on c3 sacrificing the bishop
he is forced to take okay but what
effect does that have
that shifts the pawn from b4 to c3 which
unpins the knight because the c3 pawn
um it's like a hazmat suit for these
rooks that are exerting their radiation
it's like
they don't infiltrate with their rays
anymore the knight is free to move
and that's one of the sort of beautiful
aspects of chess your own pieces could
be
the instruments of your demise
and in many cases they are and that's
the case here so
bishop c3 check b takes c3 now the
knight is free to go we could go knight
e3 we only have three pieces left but
here's the thing i am threatening knight
takes g2 checkmate as we discussed
now you might be laughing and saying are
you really think that black with a whole
move cannot stop this threat like he
can't okay he can play the move rook to
g8 for example and he can defend with
his rook
the pawn on g2 that's not the only way
to stop the threat but
one of the key things in these more
difficult problems is to detect how the
position has
changed and i mentioned this in previous
videos as a consequence of a sacrifice
any capture that is made or any trade
that is made
i always recommend you know my students
to stop pause
and think about what new squares what
new possibilities have opened up as a
result
of certain visual transformations
and if we look at this very carefully we
might see that by shifting the bishop
from c2 to d3
the c2 square has been vacated and onto
this square can land
actually a white knight that has
traveled from c4 to e3 to ostensibly go
to g2
but it now can also go to c2 and that is
also
checkmate for much the same reason again
do not forget if you're trying to
visualize this
that black c3 pawn is blocking
both of the rooks from not only pinning
the knight but by extension covering the
c2 square
and amazingly this is essentially a fork
you're forking what are you forking one
checkmate threat
and another like a fork is just an
attack by the knight of two different
things
here you're forking a checkmate which is
quite beautiful actually in a very rare
situation indeed
um and black has no way to stop both of
these
threats because he has no checks that he
can deliver against white's king so
let's execute this
and i'll pause here before playing
knight e3 because they might end the
problem there
um again look at what we've done we have
used the bishop
to block the pin and now we are going to
shift the knight from c4 to e3
where it will threaten knight takes g2
checkmate and drum roll please
knight c2 checkmate there's nothing
black can do
his bishop would have been able to pin
the knight but it's not because it's
hemmed in by this darn
rook on c7 boom knight f4 an ingenious
defensive idea he's trying to get us to
take his 994 but we could not care
less about that night we care only about
black's king and that is an observation
we made at the beginning
which would help you not get distracted
by a move like this we don't care about
material here
we care about checkmate well ladies and
gentlemen that was a very difficult
problem
that was very stimulating even to me and
you can see by the ratings here these
are serious master level problems
so i think this is actually a great time
to pause the video and we will
definitely solve
another set of six or seven videos in
the next um
six or seven videos six or seven
problems in the next video in the next
uh video in the series um and
uh i keep promising uh to solve so many
problems and i resolve relatively little
but
you know we're walking through these
it's all about quality not quantity and
uh
wow i mean incredible problem and uh
well i hope that
you guys have not only enjoyed this but
but hopefully also benefited from it
i realized as i said at the beginning
that these are high level problems
and for a beginner this could be hard to
follow but i have tried
in as much as i can to explain the
fundamental patterns the thinking
processes that
underlie undergird my ability to solve
even complicated problems now what we
see is that these complicated problems
are often composed of a set of sim of
simpler tasks
they're just put together right like we
have to escape
a series of checks and in the same
problem we also have to find like a
tactical idea and again escape a series
of checks
all in one problem so it's often
composed of a series of
simpler tasks or it often requires this
kind of imagination
such as to return to a move that you at
first abandoned
such as we did in the previous problem
look at it with a fresh pair of eyes
and ask yourself the right questions
about the position
and and sort of think of an ideal
scenario a target position and then try
to
bring that into reality which is
essentially what creativity
uh is so i'll see you in the next video
where i will be
tackling these really increasingly
difficult problems
um and i will try to do the same process
of explanation
so i hope that you have enjoyed because
i certainly have
and um as usual feel free to leave
comments constructive criticism and
advice
and stories about whether or not you
solved uh problem
number 40 well i guess problem 46
down in the comments below i will see
you uh
in the next video thank you everybody
and goodbye